there are big developments in washington
on a possible new package for gun
regulations as edelke reports president
biden and majority of senators are
behind the bill that finally emerged
from bipartisan negotiations last night
the motion is agreed to
overnight the senate took its first
steps towards passing major gun related
legislation in an attempt to address
recent mass shootings in new york texas
and california the bill is a bipartisan
deal that would expand gun background
checks for people under 21 allowing up
to 10 business days to review juvenile
and mental health records it provides
federal money for states enacting new
red flag laws designed to temporarily
seize guns from people deemed dangerous
and it closes the so-called boyfriend
loophole preventing partners convicted
of domestic abuse who live outside a
victim's home from buying a gun we have
a chance to break this
30-year period of silence it is a
compromise
it is a bipartisan
compromise there's also hundreds of
millions of dollars more for mental
health and safety resources in schools
plus tough new penalties for those that
buy and then turn around and sell a
weapon anyone barred from owning guns i
want to make sure we actually do
something useful
something that is
capable of becoming a law the national
rifle association opposes the agreement
saying it does little to truly address
violent crime and opens the door to
unnecessary burdens on the exercise of
second amendment freedom but that
doesn't seem to bother negotiators eager
to show congress can do something
anything to address gun crimes it's a
good start and i think it's going to
give us a lot of help for children
as we mentioned president biden is
supportive of this plan senate leaders
anticipate it can be passed by the end
of this week and house speaker nancy
pelosi says she hopes to hold a vote on
it as soon as possible nate
and it's a busy day at the white house
and speaking of biden what can you tell
us about president biden's latest action
to get gas prices down yeah interesting
move this morning here at the white
house the president announcing he's
calling on congress to suspend the
federal gas tax which is 18 cents for a
gallon of regular for three months so
conceivably if they pass to july one
they would run through the end of
september while the average price of gas
has come down below five dollars a
gallon the white house says this is
designed to do everything possible to
reduce costs for families especially as
the busy holiday travel season begins
nate
ed thank you